i'm definitely not in kind of like the
transhumanist
sector when it comes to anti-aging and
longevity yet at the same time i think
that by taking steps to
simultaneously increase or improve
both your lifespan and your health span
you can equip yourself to be more
impactful
and more purposeful each day with the
years that you have been given
you can equip yourself to not only be
more present in relationships or
with your grandkids or with loved ones
or active in the local community when
you're
you know 80 or 90 or 100 when others who
might not have done the same things
might be you know kind of relegated to a
wheelchair
or in a nursing home when they're when
they're 70. so
there's the impact and the purpose part
of things um
and then there's just the fact that you
know when when
you're engaging in a lot of these
anti-aging and longevity tactics
like say you know using nad
or getting out in the sunshine or using
earthing and
grounding technologies or drinking
better water
or even doing things like you know stem
cell or exosome infusions or some of
these more fringe things
as long as they're not in my opinion
taking up a disproportionate amount of
time
and energy again back back to the ironic
nature of like doing so much to live a
long time that you're spending half the
time that
you'd be living longer just doing things
to make you live longer
but as long as as you're reasonable and
responsible in your approach
i think that really the beauty of a lot
of these anti-aging
longevity tactics are a equipping
yourself to have better health span and
lifespan so you can be more impactful
with the purpose and the skill set that
god has given you
during this time that you are on the
planet no matter how long that time is
whether it's 70 or 80 or 90 or 150 you
know it's about
impact and purpose and being fully
functional and then b
this is the part that you know i
recently addressed this on a beauty and
anti-aging podcast that i did with a
local uh
um physician who does things like you
know uh
hair treatments and prp for the face and
wrinkle treatments and
you know working on symmetry and beauty
of the body i think that
having a certain amount of pride in your
image
and how you look as you age is
reasonable you know and i'm not i'm not
a fan of like
you know let's say women who are six
years old
walking around looking like they're
trying to be 20 year old college
students i think it
often just pulls off a look like a a lot
of these women they just almost look
like old hookers
but you know just like you know fake
boobs and the botox treatments and
the clothing that really is more
appropriate for someone who's
40 years younger i i mean i think that
that that aspect of the beauty movement
is
again like fear of death running from
the changes that you should be accepting
as honorable changes for your body
and just to shift into another chapter
of life but at the same time
like i think you can be beautiful and
handsome and symmetrical
and well kept and well put together as
you age
due to a lot of these things like say
maybe doing a clay mask every week and
doing some
derma rolling or micro needling for your
scalp or making sure that you stay
fit and symmetrical and working on
mobility and doing all these things to
stay kind of
put together and even arguably beautiful
as you age
and i think that that's good because it
gives you self-confidence
i think it shows that you care for and
respect the body
that you've been given and let's face it
if
you're in this to fulfill maslow's
hierarchy of needs to care for your
family to feed yourself to make an
income etc
we know that people who care for
themselves you know they they tend to
get paid more they tend to get hired and
better positions they tend to get
respected more they tend to get taken
more seriously
so you know i i certainly think that
there's
something to responsible embracing of
the beauty
movement in anti-aging as well i think
it all depends on the lens through which
you view these things
and the reason in your heart that you're
doing them and if
it is noble and sound and to be able to
be
more impactful and make other people
around you feel more comfortable
and have more self-confidence in
yourself you know i i love a lot of
these tactics and
you know i was originally what boundless
was going to be like i sat down to write
that book three years ago
as a book on anti-aging and longevity
know as you can see the chapter on
anti-aging and longevity in that book is
like 150 pages long
but the you know i realize that there's
just so many pathways
that you have to take care of if you
want to age gracefully like the immune
system
and the gut and the brain and the
muscles
and the lymph and you know all these
different factors that
the book kind of morphed into just an
all-encompassing blueprint for the human
body
with certain chapters on longevity but
you know that was originally i was super
interested in that book just being about
anti-aging longevity and realized
you really can't so much more take that
without addressing everything else
so much more